hello everyone and welcome to one of the
craziest games you'll ever see and
surprise surprise who is playing it of
course a rashidun is MIDI note
the game was played in 1964 it was a
children Memorial Tournament in Sochi
and Rashida Schmidt you know faces
Slovak International Master Maximilian
with del key and aside from being a
chess chess international master he also
competed for the for the Czechoslovakian
and Olympia team three times and it is
said that he's a direct descendant of
famous Hungarian composer Franz Liszt
something seems like an interesting bit
of information so let's check out this
game and I did prepare as we haven't had
a photo challenge for quite a while as I
you know pre-recorded the videos before
I left for Dubrovnik I did I decided to
give you one so best of luck to everyone
who are the two gentlemen in this photo
so there you have it
and also it's a very nice chess board if
I do say so myself
so there you have it enjoy now let's
check out this game that should be one
of the craziest games ever in this in
this game you will see a defense by
black that resembles the hippopotamus
defense and also something called the
Whittell key system as he played this
quite a lot with the black pieces and
was known to be the hero of the hippo as
he employed it in very strong encounters
so II for g6
we have D for better to g7 so black
still you know can transpose into
anything Knight to c3 d6 Bishop to c4 we
have E six Knight to f3 Knight to e7 and
now Russia goes for the immediate h4 as
Black is still you know deciding what to
play but this is something that is quite
common for for black when he goes for
this hippopotamus defense are placing
the Knight to d7 and also to e7 and here
as you know there is a nice target on g6
a rush it immediately was for h4 black
is still kind of you know keeping
everything open and this is something
you will see very often if black
continues we
early goes with the early g6 or if a
player with the white pieces is 11 RM so
we have h 6 and now brush up to f4 now i
pushing age 5 doesn't really make a
whole lot of sense as this will be met
with g5 so after age 6 brush up to f4
and now a six Queen e2 we have nice to
d7 and now a for preventing b5 we have
b6
rock to d1 and now worship to b7 King to
f1 we have nice to f8 Rema nuvaring and
now King back to g1 Queen to see it and
here comes a Bishop to b3 Queen d7 I
would have rocked to h3 and rook to d8
now so if you look at this position it's
quite an unorthodox position the white
king is in g1 the rock is on h3 but
Rasheed pushed the h4 pawn as well as da
for porn and as you can see both its you
know black can really do anything is his
king is still stuck on e8 but it's not
all that easy to take advantage of this
the Knights and the bishop are doing an
excellent job defending and this Bishop
is very well placed on b7 so mushroom
back to C for attacking the a sec spawn
as the Queen moved from c8 so Queen back
to c8 mushroom back to be 3 and now f6
we tell key doesn't repeat Queen d7 rook
to e1 and now comes King to f7 trying
also to artificially castle but also to
support the pawns Bishop back to c1 and
now c6 there were a lot of moves
possible in this position but I mean
could you really resist playing c6 in
this position and creating this very
nice structure night to d2 we have d 5
now and a 5 we have B 5 and now nice to
f3 Queen to c7 Bishop to d2 we have
brush up to c8 and now Knight back to a
to nice to h7 nice to be for now and the
HH rock comes the e8 nice the d3 we have
nice to f8 and now Bishop to f4
attacking the Queen a very nice idea
right in this Medina
he can he kind of forces black to
capture this point but it's a very nice
idea Queen captures on a fight was
played and now comes a five we take we
tell key lock down the position with f5
and now comes the bishop back to d2
attacking the Queen Queen moves and now
comes rock to a-1 here in is Medina is
preparing Bishop to a5 to win the two in
the exchange as the rock is still in the
eighth and he did create something out
of the position but trying to prevent
this with something like Queen B 8 so
the rock and move will be met actually
with h5 and now the queen is simply too
far away to do anything g5 now comes
Knight captures pawn captures and Bishop
captures h6 is coming so you do have to
move the bishop
either way white will push h6 and after
Knight 2h7 now comes queen h5 check this
was the whole point King moves and now
Bishop captures King captures and Queen
to g6 attacking the knight Knight has to
move and you don't really have a lot of
options here and I'd move pawn captures
Bishop captures and now h7 and the white
will break through here so quite you
know definitely a critical position and
here Maximilian with elk he makes a very
interesting decision he plays in 92 h7
immediately starts defending against
this threat and allows the Bishop to a5
here we do have butter to a5 Queen moves
and now Bishop captures on d8 so very
interesting you know turn of events that
it's actually news Medina of who is up
the exchange rope captures and now Queen
to d2 so what's what's the idea here
Queen to d2 of course you might want to
start pushing the H pawn and then after
g5 sacrifice tonight via Knight to g5
not immediately but perhaps after the
knight moves from a 7 but also Queen a5
to attack in the rock and e8 will also
be an idea
Bishop to b7 Queen does come to a5 now
and now rook to e8
protecting the ASX pawn nice the c5 and
now comes a bishop to c8 getting out of
Knights reach c3 and now nice to f8 so
although Medina is up there
change it's not all that easy to break
through here here he plays night Stewie
one nightly one I have no idea if if
ninja Medina of blundered upon here but
or maybe he did this on purpose to try
and break through the position you can
it's very hard to tell but he allowed
Bishop captures any five of course now
if pawn captures Quinn will be able to
capture on c5 but he did go for this D
captures on e5 Queen captures on c5 and
now tonight the d3 attacking the Queen
so it's still hard to say that he go for
this or did he bond or a pawn queen back
to a seven and now Bishop back to c2 we
have C five now and here be four Knights
the c6 attacking the Queen Queen to a3
and now c4 Knight comes to c5 and now a
knight captures on e5 so grabbing and
yet another pawn queen to c1 now
threatening to go to h6 grabbing the
spawn and now h5 rope to g3 Queen to h6
immediately doesn't really give white
all that much so we have rocked to g3
and now Knight e to D seven offering a
trade Knight captures on e6 here Knight
captures on d7 was the correct the
correct way to go and Queen captures on
d7 and now Rashida still up the exchange
and you know you're gonna play this
position but here after 90 d7 Rashid
decided to play Knight captures on e6 he
he refuses to be up material we have
Knight captures on e6 and now comes
Queen to h6 threatening Queen captures
on g6 here Knight d2 f8 was played it's
a very precise idea and the only correct
idea if you try and defend with this
then already knows idea was Bishop
captures on f5 pawn captures and rook to
e1 completely cutting off the King here
and the next move Queen g7 would be
checkmate so after Queen f6 Knight d2 f8
protecting the g6 pawn and now comes
Bishop captures an f5 nevertheless G
captures an f5 and now rook to e1
and his reading of proceeds with his
plan Bishop to d7 and now comes Queen
captures on h5 King 37 and now Queen
captures on f5 so we tell his is up
material and he has a better position
buttress Rasheed is making it very hard
for him to prove it
King d6 tucking the king away at the
safety h5 now Russia doesn't have much
but he does have a passed pawn and
passed pawns must be pushed
a5 Queen to e5 this comes with check
King c6 and rook to d1 now threatening
Queen captures and d5 so night to c7
simply defending the pawn rope to a-1
now not allowing a capture Sun before
and although you could push a 4 here
instead the Queen to be a displayed
we have pawn captures on a 5 and now B
for C capture some before and now Queen
captures on b4 rook to f3 and here
Knight the e6 we have a 6 of course you
cannot capture the pawn immediately as
rook captures and f8 will follow but
Knight to c6 now defending the f8 look
at the DFA at night and now you can
actually capture the pawn on a 5 so a 6
we have Queen to c5 and here comes Queen
to e1 Queen to you one a very nice move
you know keeping everything in order and
prepare rook to a5 a very nice rock
lifts that will kick away the black
Queen and also perhaps to start a very
nice attack Knights to d4 attacking the
rook on f3 and here comes rook to f6
check night f2 e 6 blocking and here
comes a rock to a5 attacking the Queen
Queen to b6 the best idea and now comes
h6 and there's Medina pushes the other
passport as well King to d6 it was it's
a nice idea but Queen to be two would
have been would have been better with
the idea of this check followed by Queen
cap Queen captures rook on f6 so this
would have definitely be a better active
move but okay King these six and here we
have h 7 - Medina
c3 now we tell key starts pushing
his own passport as well and here we
have rook back to a-1 Queen captures on
c3 if you do this then you get a nice to
eat to check of course you lose the
Queen so that's not really something you
want to do after c3 rook to a-1 and here
we have C - we tell key found a way to
push his own past pawn as well
rook to g6 the idea of course being
rocked rock to g7 or a rock to g8 either
forcing an exchange but also threatening
h8 Queen so look to h8 preventing it and
the now comes a 7 there's million of
pushes yet another pass pawn and here
comes Queen to be - here we have a look
to h6 rope to h6 is a very dangerous
move but there's really not all that
much to do here if you try something
like a 8 and bring the Queen into the
game you simply get rook captures and
have to rock captures see one with
another Queen and now the game is over
for white
another thing after this Queen to be to
move you could try something like rook
to g8 but even this doesn't help you it
seems like a valid idea simply block the
rook and then bring a queen into the
game but this actually loses the night e
to check its that yes
that's simple after Queen captures now
Queen captures rook and it's all over
and even if you don't capture it even if
you try something like King - h1 then
you get rook captures on h7 and this is
now checkmate and on the other hand if
you go to f1 then again you get rook
captures on h7 and it doesn't matter if
you bring another queen hunter game
you're getting rook h1 check King
captures and now simply a double check
from the Queen and the night you've just
promoted from a pawn a king has to move
Queen d4 chair king or queen a 4 this
will be checkmate
so not definitely not gonna go with rook
the g8 so what can you do here here is
Medina I've tried rook to h6
simply defending the h7 pawn and you
know keeping all of his options open but
this was actually a terrible blunder but
fortunately for him I Maximilian hotel
key did not figure it out he played
Knight to e2 and he thought that this
was just as crushing but it's
Knight to f3 wins the game immediately
on the spot now if you capture the night
then you get Queen g7 check King moves
and now comes the Bishop to b5 check or
you go to the H file and then Queen
captures rook King F 1 now Bishop checks
and you don't really have any options
here Queen e2 and you don't even have to
capture the Queen first first Queen
captures on a1 with check King moves
Quinjet back to g7 check King moves and
only now Queen to see one and this will
be checkmate so definitely a very nice
move with Alchemist
so instead of this night to have three
very crushing movie played Knight to e2
check you thought it was all the same
but it's not we have King to h2 and now
comes c1 Queen rook captures Knight
captures and here Queen to a5
threatening to bring another Queen into
the game we tail key defense this Bishop
to c6 and the now comes Queen to a six
black is still better but you know if
you if he could have finished again with
Knight to f3 check immediately Queen to
e5 check g3 and now comes Knight to b3
we have f4 measurement you know is
really really going all out this game
this is this is really some Kong futures
Queen B to check we have King to h3 and
in this position
Maximillian we tell T played Knights the
c5 and after rush it brought another
Queen into the game he decided to resign
the game so it seems like extremely
complicated position with a whole lot of
variations available but the truth is
it's not really here after Knight
characters Queen on e6 and Queen
captures night and a6 there's really not
all that much for white to do after
Queen to c1 for example you're a threat
you're guarding against rook captures
night followed by Queen captures Bishop
also you're not allowing whites to give
any checks you're regarding gay 3 square
and most importantly you're not allowing
f5 to attack the pin piece as if you
move the pond and Queen captures rook is
coming of course so here after this
Queen was brought into the game a
Rashida's Medina resigned the game after
a couple of moves for example here you
could try something like Queen to a2 as
Queen to h1 is a big threat to pick up
the rock on h8 and after Queen here
Queen here you can capture and after
King captures now simply the dd4 would
win the game and I will I will show this
variation until the end as it's very
interesting you can even give up a night
here and after d3 rook captures king D 5
you have to block the pawn and have
sturdy to rook d1 now you play king d4
and this is crushing you even give up
the pawn rook captures now you play King
III and now it's a very nice ending rook
has the move rook captures king g1 and
now rook to h1 checkmate as now the king
is covering f2 so very nice that they
are pushing the pawn simply to get the
e3 with tempo and checkmate the White
King so a very nice very nice game
bye-bye both of them you know creating
such an insane game in 86 move moves
with who knows how many Queens on the
board and in the end a Maximilian we
talk is flow international master
managed to defeat a Rashid Desmond
enough but yeah definitely one of the
craziest games I've ever seen you know
definitely you know similar to a lot of
towels games especially the one he
played against goblins that's a really
insane game as well if you haven't seen
it I will put a link to it in the
description below if you like games like
this so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed that as usual you can check
to all my previous videos here think all
for watching and I will see you as soon
as I'm almost back from Dubrovnik thank
you